hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel in this video
i want to talk about rent to rent what
is it how do you do it how do you make
sure that it's not illegal and where are
the best areas for rent to rent so
before i start talking about that though
please do me a messy favor and smash the
like button also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel which you can do
below and turn the notification bell on
rent to rent is when you rent a property
you pay an agreed amount but then you
put another tenant in the property now
you have to do this with the right
contracts you have to do this with the
right permission but this is an
extremely smart way now i've just been
speaking to a really good friend of mine
who's also one of my students called
natasha and she has scaled her rent to
rent a rent business so cleverly she
started out
by renting a house okay her and her
family were in the house her sisters her
sisters moved out when they went to uni
and she thought hmm
could i just rent the rooms out in the
house that i'm renting so she stayed
living in the house but then she then
put lodgers in the property those
lodgers
paid for the entire rent of the house so
natasha was living rent free she thought
hang on a minute
this is awesome i want to buy a house i
want to act
i want to get more into this property
stuff so she became a student of mine
she started watching videos like crazy
and she bought a house and guess what
she did with the house that she bought
she lived in it residential house small
deposit down okay very easy to get on
the property ladder when you when you're
a residential first time buyer there's
so many incentives but that's for
another video so she moved into the
property but then what do you think she
did she rented out two of the rooms that
meant that she was living free again
she had so much demand
for these lodges like can i rent the
rooms can i read the rooms that she then
rented another house okay down the road
two minutes that right around the corner
that she's in london by the way she
rented a house for 600 pounds a month
and then put three tenants in the house
and was making a thousand pounds a month
clean profit from that property so rent
to rent is a very very effective way how
you can cash flow positive from property
and you don't even have to own the
property so if you want to know more
about rent to rent you can ask questions
below in the comment box but also i am
going to be running next week
a free training program live in person
i'm doing a tour up and down the country
and i'd like to invite you to come meet
me in person and learn about rent to
rent so that you can become financially
free this year in 2021. did you know
that you can make money from property
without even owning the property
this is possible through
rent to rent in the same way that amazon
does own most of their stock and uber
don't own their taxis and airbnb don't
own their hotels
you do not have to own property to
control property and make money through
property i have helped so many of my
students become financially free by
controlling properties because they've
learned how to utilize rent to rent
stella has done it in oxford endrit has
done it in london tom has done it in
huddersfield and now it's your turn
where you can do the exact same thing
too in your city so come and join me on
the rent to rent revolution where i will
personally be sharing the secrets that
you need to become financially free via
rent to rent and the best part is the
course is completely
free what are you waiting for get your
ticket booked right now and i'll see you
soon
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
you can subscribe up here also if you
want to watch more videos like this you
can check out our whole playlist up here
and i look forward to seeing you at the
rents around revolution real soon peace
[Music]
you